Hello ! Ouais, là je
je fais une vidéo, je me suis pris
quelque not sur papier, c'est
juste la value que je vais dropper même
sur le contexte de CL code, comment
l'améliorer, comment pfiner puis où que
j'en suis rendu pour l'améliorer. Donc
directement, on va commencer
à euh ben voir ce que euh qui est
important que moi j'avais complèement
oublié. C'est où que tuouvres Claude
Code. Moi c'est l'erreur en partant que
j'ai fait. J'ouvrais Claude Code même
pas dans le document. Je l'ouvrais
juste, j'écrivais terminal sur Windows,
j' prumer terminal fait que j'appara sur
Windows euh
quelque chose d' puis là je j'écrivais
Claud puis je startais Claude Claude
Claude code là-dedans.
L'affaire que ça fait dans ce tempslà
c'est que Claude COD est complèement
perdu. Si tu lui parles de travailler
sur un projet ou peu importe, il y a il
y a aucune idée où qu' travaille, où
qu'il va faire ce document ou qu'il va
aller chercher le contexte. Il y en a
aucune idée. Fa que là, il va chercher,
il va chercher dans ton ordi, pu il va
trouver l'information. Mais le problème
est c'est quand qu'il va construire,
qui va commencer à construire fait des
documents et cetera, des ressources.
Puis là, ça fait que lui il va il va par
exemple moi il mettait ça dans mon
desktop.
Dans mon desktop puis dans mon desktop,
j'avais un Obsy Vol qui est mon Obsidan
V, c'est mon second cerveau avec toutes
mes informations. Donc le contexte
global était dans mon Obsidian V. Mais
lui par exemple, des fois ça dépendait
des des sessions parce que moi je
l'ouvrais je l'ouvrais dans un terminal
comme random un peu mais dans un dossier
random fait que là lui il cherchait puis
c'était un peu aléatoire il savait pas
aussi qu' allait construire fait que des
fois il construisait dans mon desktop
directement fait qu' mettait des
documents là-dedans mais des fois il
allait dans le desktop mais dans le
document Obsidian V puis là il y avait
tout mon contexte global puis build
làdedans. Puis moi c'était cette
deuxième partie là que je voulais. Moi
c'est la partie aussi qui allait build
dans mon second cerveau que je voulais
qui bu mais des fois il faisait dans
desktop. Fait que ça crée des
incohérences, ça crée des doublons. Fait
point numéro 1, c'est le contexte que tu
que le le contexte dans lequel touvre
Claude code qui est super important.
Euh par la suite, je vais vous donner
juste des des automatisations pour
améliorer votre votre second cerveau
continuellement.
Mais d'abord, je pense que un des gros
points, c'est les routines. Donc routine
de début de session, routine de fin de
session. fait par exemple routine de
début de session, ça pourrait être va
lire toutes mes courriels, euh
va lire tout ce que on a fait dans la
dernière session, euh va voir où on est
rendu dans tel tel projet, puis dis-moi
les pistes à suivre pour les prochaines
pour la prochaine session, qu'est-ce
qu'on devrait faire ? les priorités, ça
pourrait être un exemple de début de de
routine de début de session. Puis par la
suite, une routine de fin de session
avec par exemple euh fais un résumé de
tout de tout ce qu'on a vu. Euh va euh
je sais pas, on va prendre des notes sur
les apprentissages qu'on a fait
ensemble, l'avancement des projets, va
mettre à jour les documents et cetera
puis il va aller mettre à jour les
documents pour la fin de session. Ce qui
va faire que plus que tu vas avancer
dans t dans des discussions avec Claud
code, plus qu'il va apprendre, il va
prendre des notes sur les anciennes
sessions puis il va fait qu' il va
terminer la session, il va aller les
chiper à la prochaine session qui va
aller, tu vas tout travailler avec elle,
qui va apprendre de tout ça fait tes
feedback, ce que vous avez travaillé,
l'avancement et cetera, les sources de
problème et cetera, les tout ça puis
vacher super pas à même place fait tu
vas tout le temps même de monter comme
ça avec l'autre code. Puis tu vas monter
puis en efficacité, tu vas apprendre à
te connaître de plus en plus c'est quoi
tes c'est quoi tes attentes, c'est quoi
tes besoins puis tout ça.
Très important.
Euh par la suite ajouter un workflow NM
pour des Audis euh ben faire un workflow
qui se starte une fois par semaine, par
exemple la le dimanche pour faire un
audiers complet ton de tout ton
contexte.
Donc de voir est-ce queil y a des
dossiers, des doublons, est-ce qu'il y a
des dossiers perdus, des inutiles,
peut-être qu'il y a des failles dans le
système dans les dans dans le contexte
puis vraiment d'aller tout faire un
audit de tout ça fait à chaque dimanche
automatisation bom un Audi qui se fait
toute ta structure de contexte puis vous
allez vous allez voir vous allez me voir
venir. La deuxième automatisation, c'est
corriger tout ça, apprendre des erreurs
puis améliorer.
Euh
par la suite, un workflow qui
hiérarchise, qui compresse les vieux
contextes, donc qui va aller analyser
toutes tes euh
tes contextes, toutes tes dossiers, les
hiérarchiser. qu'est-ce qui est moins
important, qu'est-ce qui est vieux,
qu'est-ce qui est peut-être inutile
maintenant puis d'aller les compresser
puis peut-être aller vraiment diminuer
le volume, la grandeur du contexte parce
qu'on sait que l' plus tu un contexte
qui est énorme, plein d'information puis
surtout que plus tu ajoutes
d'information, plus c'est difficile de
structurer.
En tout cas, ça dépend des fois mais
l'idéal c'est pas un contexte qui est
énorme pu c'est pour ça de compresser
des stocks qui sont peut-être moins
utiles maintenant.
Euh
euh WFlow qui analyse des relations
entre les notes. Donc avoir euh moi
j'utilise Obsidian pour toute ma prise
de note. Donc mon second cerveau est
dans Obsidienne. Puis dans Obsidienne,
tu peux faire des liens entre les
concepts. Donc par exemple, c'est un je
sais pas un document sur ta stratégie go
to market puis je sais pas moi les
tuas un autre document qui c'est tes
tactiques de sales ou peu importe ou ton
ton CRM, ben d'avoir des liens qui se
créent entre tes idées qui peut euh
Claud aller se promener là-dedans puis
faire des liens entre les idées pour
vraiment avoir une certaine créativité
qui se crée au travers des des
interliens qui se font entre les
concepts puis même avec tes lectures que
tu as fait tes notes de lecture et
cetera pour qu'il y ait des des liens
qui se font pour que créer un réseau de
neuron qui appelle pour que l' devienne
de plus en plus intelligente et fasse
des liens entre toutes les concepts pour
qu'elle pas juste
de quoi générique mais de quoi qui est
vraiment focus puis
créatif possible comment créatif mais
en comprend
Euh
oui, un autre automatisation d'avoir euh
Lia qui va trouver des opportunité en
fonction des news qu'il a eu dans les
dernières semaines. Donc peut-être que
tu pourrais starter le même workflow en
même temps que l'autre le dimanche puis
qu' a analyser toutes les news de la
dernière semaine. Donc peut-être d tout
mettre les grands journaux les grands
journaux les white combinators de ce
monde tout ce qui est en lien avec la
tech voir les opportunités business puis
avoir l' qui va aller analyser ça voir
qu'est-ce qui s'applique à tes projets
puis te dire te poser les solutions
puis en parallèle de ça peut-être
ajuster une fonctionir les nouveaux
repos Getub toutes les nouvelles
propositions de
ce qui a été créé sur les communautés
euh Getub puis tout ça puis d' analyser
ton analyser ce qui ce qui se fait ce
qui est comme trendy dans les euh dans
la dernière semaine par exemple puis ton
contexte le comparer qu'est-ce qui
pourrait se faire pour améliorer ton
contexte euh
puis c'est ça avoir un
jeu va à à la hausse ben en rafale avoir
une loop de self
improvement, donc qui s'améliore
continuellement, avoir une loop qui va
aller analyser les erreurs, les
mauvaises réponses, les répétitions, les
pertes de contexte puis qui va améliorer
ça puis solidifier tout ça. par la suite
avoir euh les un problème tracker donc
avoir les qui c'est les priorités les
états, les solutions testées, les causes
probables des problèmes pour qu'elle
s'améliore puis qu'elle apprenne de tout
ça puis qu' elle sache identifier puis
spotter les erreurs possibles.
Euh avoir une loop qui retient le
pourquoi tu as pris les décisions de
telle telle telle manière. Donc
peut-être avoir une loop de qui te pose
des questions de OK, tu as décidé telle
chose, pourquoi tu as décidé ça au lieu
de ça ? Puis pourquoi ça dans cette
ordre là ? Puis pourquoi ? Pour que Lia
apprenne
comment toi tu réfléchis
pour que par la suite elle soit autonome
à réfléchir comme toi.
Puis je pense qu'on va arrêter là, mais
vous comprendrez que l'objectif c'est
que Lia apprenne comment tu fonctionnes,
comment tu réfléchis.
Donc là, tu ploges comment toi tu
réfléchis à tout le contexte
macroéconomique, les news, la tech puis
tes projets être capable de t'aider au
maximum puis de te guider là-dedans avec
une intelligence qui est euh
exponentiellement
énorme. Je sais pas comment mieux le
dire mais euh tu pour dire que ton
contexte de Lia
c'est euh la priorité absolue. C'est ça
qui va faire la grosse différence entre
ceux qui utilisent du chat GPT pour leur
liste d'épicerie.
ceux qui utilisent qui commence à
l'utiliser mant avec du cloud code puis
ess d'explorer les skills puis essaie de
pluger leur Gmail des réponses tout ça
puis ceux qui ont tout building leur
infrastructure leur contexte pour qu'il
y a des autoritérations
de leur système pour que l' apprenne sur
eux puis qu' elle soit connectée au aux
différentes ressources puis qu'elle
apprenne de tout ça puis qu'elle s'auto
réitère
pour qu'elle devienne le plus autonome.
possible. Elle apprend à te connaître
davantage
puis là tu es rendu avec une machine de
guerre pour les prochaines années. Puis
la différence exponentielle entre toutes
les autres personnes qui utilisent mal.
Donc si tu avais un devoir à faire
peut-être c'est
fais un Audi à chat GPT
OK fais-moi un prompt comme si tu étais
un pro dev puis fais un audi complète de
toute ma structure de tout mon contexte
de cloud code
puis
donne ça à Claude Code puis CL va faire
un audi complet de tout ta ton contexte
ça puis ben point numéro
Si tuas pas de contexte, tuutilises
cloud.
Continue écouter mes vidéos puis on va
parler. Salut.